the highest-ranking Catholic leader ever
charged with child sex abuse was found
guilty molesting two boys in Australia
Cardinal George Pell a top adviser to
Pope Francis was convicted back in
December but but a court had forbidden
publication of any details about the
trial until right now he abused two boys
moments after a Sunday Mass back in 1996
Seth Doane is in Rome with details on
that Seth good morning to you good
morning that gag order had been put in
place by an Australian Court to avoid
the possibility of prejudicing a jury
and a possible second trial that is now
not taking place today the Vatican is
saying that this is just the first stage
of a legal process and since Cardinal
Pell has maintained his innocence
innocence his legal team has filed an
appeal the Vatican will wait until the
conclusion of that process to make any
next steps now earlier Cardinal Pell was
heckled as he left the Melbourne
courthouse surrounded by police and
mobbed by reporters the Cardinal was
convicted of sexually abusing two
13-year old boys in 1996 at a Melbourne
Cathedral Feld was 55 years old at the
time and was also in charge of the local
churches program to combat sex abuse the
Vatican today said that Pope Francis was
standing by was confirming his position
and restrictions on Cardinal Pell
including that he should abstain from
public ministry and that he should avoid
contact with minors until this appeal
process is complete now we know that
Cardinal Pell faces up to 50 years in
jail Seth Doane in Rome Thank You Seth